What are your thoughts about oxalates?
Well, oxalates are a bigger problem if you have a lot of defects on your oxalate detoxification
gene.
So people that have a lot of defects on that oxalates become a bigger problem can't get rid
of them.
They can form stones and cause kidney stones and other stones.
But even someone who doesn't have any issues on their, remember, your genes are just a picture.
They're just a photograph of possibilities.
So a person, let's say, have zero defects, single or double LLG defects on any, unemory
single oxalate gene, they're perfectly clean and they can get kidney stone.
Why is that?
Because it doesn't need just because you don't have defects that you still don't have issues
with detoxifying, not just oxalates, but other things.
So if you don't detoxify oxalates very well, they can build up with your kidneys and they
can cause stones in other places too.
So oxalates can be an issue, but it's like everything with moderation.
So with some people, especially people that have defects, they can be highly sensitive to oxalates
and notice your health when they consume foods with a greater amount of oxalates.
Now, again, just kind of test yourself, boy, do I feel worse when I eat rhubarb?
Yes, I do.
Okay, well, maybe you have oxalate issues.
No, I don't at all.
Well, maybe you don't have oxalate issues, even if you do have defects, maybe you're detoxing
them very well.
Remember detoxification is a fluid flow of this river going through you.
It doesn't need them just because I have detox detox issues today that I might not have them
tomorrow.
It's constantly flowing, this river is flowing.
So you do it everything you can to keep this river moving at a rate that's acceptable to
get rid of poisons that you're exposed to, even things that are in foods that are good for
us.
So you just keep working on that river to get things out of your body that you don't want.